[Music]
hey all i'm back again and we're talking
about some more horror books
now the one we're talking about today i
talked about this on my uh
tbr video uh for 2021
this one is called hex by thomas old
hoyvelt hopefully i'm pronouncing that
correctly
so let's get a little background on this
book now this book
uh the author is dutch and uh the book
actually came out in the netherlands
in the dutch language in 2013
and was apparently a real big hit there
so i guess he had uh his agents and they
uh sold the english language rights so
at which point he decided he would get
to
essentially rewrite it it is it was
actually translated
by a woman named nancy forrest flyer
but the author uh you know even though
he is dutch and dutch is his native
language
uh he also speaks several other
languages fluently including english
so he was actually able to work with the
translator and he was
uh basically saying that this kind of
gave me
he calls it in the end notes he called
it he calls it a hex 2.0
he's like i could basically you know
change the setting of the book and i
could change the ending if i wanted to
and i could change some particular
things to go
along with more of like an american
cultural thing rather than a dutch
cultural thing
while still keeping all the things that
i liked from the story
so that's um apparently what he did now
obviously i don't speak dutch
so i don't know how the um the dutch
version of the book differs from the
english one he said the ending is
actually
quite radically different which i don't
think i'm going to spoil because i don't
i don't really want to like spoil the
end of this because the end of it does
get
pretty crazy which i'll kind of get into
in a little bit okay so the interesting
thing about this book
one it's this sounded like from the um
description this pretty much sounded
like right
up my alley because i love old school
wit [ __ ] and i just feel like there's
not enough of that
you know what i mean i just feel like
there's too many movies and too many
books and stuff like that i have like
zombies and vampires and even werewolves
like to a lesser extent
and ghosts which you know all of that is
cool and i've enjoyed a lot of those but
i just feel like
old school witch kind of stuff like
folklore witch kind of stuff
is a little thin on the ground and
that's kind of a bummer
so when i saw this one recommended i was
just kind of like oh man you know that
sounds really really awesome like i love
that kind of like folklore
like old school new england witch stuff
so i really really got this book now
i will say i
liked this book i didn't love it and i'm
having a hard time articulating
maybe why that is i don't know i i feel
like i didn't connect with the
characters all that much and it tonally
it was a little strange
that said overall i found it really
entertaining and i found like some of
the imagery in it really creepy
and i thought i think the best thing
about it is
the concept of the story whether it was
really completely or successfully
realized um not really sure
i mean maybe not for me it's weird
because i did read some
uh reviews of this on goodreads and this
seems to be one where people
really really really loved it or really
really hated it and
you know dnf'd it you know some people
were like 19 25
and i read some of the negative reviews
of it and i could kind of see where they
were coming from with it i'm not sure i
agree with it entirely
but you know everyone's mileage will
vary
obviously so here's the concept of this
book which as i said
is a fantastic concept now the original
dutch version of the book was actually
set in the netherlands it was set in a
small
dutch village this version the english
language version has been
transferred to a small town in
upstate new york in the hudson river
valley so with all of that kind of stuff
that that implies you know very
old school like new england folklore
witchcraft lore that kind of stuff
so he moved it uh to there to this very
very small town it's only like three
four thousand people something like that
so basically this town which is called
black spring
several hundred years ago like 300
something years ago
there was a woman who lived there named
catherine
and she was accused of being a witch now
from everything that i could determine
she actually was a witch so like you
know i guess the accuser
the accusation was spot on um but yeah
so she actually was a witch
you know she didn't really seem to be
harming the town at first but of course
all the townsfolk were freaking out and
they were all superstitious and she got
blamed
for a lot of stuff that maybe was not
her fault
so they essentially made her a pariah
what her son dies
like her little boy dies and she
allegedly
brought the kid back to life using
witchcraft it's not really
ever determined whether this actually
happened or not but the townsfolk
believed that it did
at which point um as i said they kind of
dragged her before the entire town
accused her of witchcraft you know
necromancy or whatever and there's like
basically
either kill the sun that you brought
back from the dead or we're gonna kill
your other kid who is a daughter
and then probably kill you as well so
essentially making her choose between
her two children
now since this terrible incident 300
years in the past
the town of black spring has been cursed
the witch is kind of still around which
i'll get to in a bit
if you were born in black spring you
cannot leave if you leave
for any length of time like you can
leave for short periods of time
but the longer you're gone the more the
curse of black spring starts
getting into your head and it will
eventually make you kill yourself
and if you move to black spring you also
cannot leave
so when you come there like you can
visit there and they have tourists come
they have a whole salem
massachusetts thing going on where they
let outsiders in uh you know they have
these
festivals that are based around
catherine the witch um
you know it and it's mitigated and it's
actually kind of funny so like i said
i'll get into that a little bit too
but there's this so there's this whole
like miasma about the town
that if you live there you're stuck
there
essentially uh so at the start of the
book
you're having a new couple the dela
rosas
and they are moving from new york city
they're very you know high-powered city
people and they're
you know looking to get out of the rat
race as a lot of people do it's like oh
let's find a nice little
berg up in upstate new york somewhere
and find this beautiful little house
and uh something that when new people
move there i guess like what the
townsfolk tried they try
their damnedest to get people not to
move there because obviously
you know when you do move there the town
council has to tell you
guess what you can never leave um you
know and we have all of these rules and
laws
about how we're getting how we deal with
the witch and how we deal with the witch
curse
so the delarosas um they don't really
figure i they didn't figure into the
story as much as i thought they would
because they were kind of
not major characters but it was kind of
a big thing at the beginning i guess
they were just sort of introduced
so you could you know see
the way the town operated from the point
of view of somebody that was just coming
there because then the council had
somebody to
explain it to like explain all the rules
so basically the witch catherine
is still around she's kind of like i
mean obviously she's dead
but she's kind of like a ghost in the
sense that she can sort of like
pop around wherever she wants to like
she can turn up in your living room
suddenly um you know if she hangs out
somewhere long enough and starts to get
annoyed
she disappears so she can do that but
she's also corporeal as in uh
you can touch her she can run into
things stuff like that so she's like a
person and a ghost at the same time
which i thought was kind of like a
really cool concept
now the thing about this town and the
first part of the book is
almost like a black comedy and this is
what i mean when this
when i say the tone of this is kind of
strange because at the beginning
it almost like the idea of this witch
just being able to like pop up in your
[ __ ] house all the time
creepy um and actually the the author
thomas heuvelt he said that he got the
idea after he saw
or he read roald dahl's the witches and
saw the movie that came out in 1990
and he's like just the thought of a
witch being able to like pop up
wherever freaked him the [ __ ] out and
you know like traumatized him for
six months or something after he saw the
movie because he was a kid
so he really really liked that idea and
wanted to like traumatize other people
with it
so like i said if you think about it the
fact that there's a witch oh and i
forgot to mention too that at some point
i think after she was already dead but
she was still
kind of popping up all over the town um
somebody managed to
hold her down and sew her mouth shut and
so her eyes shut
so she is like really freaky looking now
at some point
somebody did cut one stitch off of the
off of her mouth
i think it was in 1967 and it was like a
huge disaster like all these people
dropped dead and everything because
one of the things that she has one she
has an evil eye
and two she can whisper to you
and get you to kill yourself like i said
so you know
in really really horrific ways so
basically
over the centuries uh after all of this
experimentation has failed they have
tried to kill her they try to get rid of
her and it doesn't work
so at this point the book is said in
2012 the town has come to
sort of an uneasy peace with the witch
they have all these rules
surrounding what you can and cannot do
it's funny because they have this whole
like technological they have like this
bunker
like in the town and all of the town all
the outside areas of the town are under
surveillance
and um so they can keep track of where
she's at
and they also have an app that you can
put on your phone
and when the witch turns up in your
house you're supposed to mark that
that's where she is
and then when she leaves you have to
mark again so they always have
so they always know where she's at so
they can keep track of her because
no one is entirely sure why she's still
hanging out no one is entirely sure
what she wants um if she's trying to
take revenge on the town and as i said
because her eyes and mouth are sewn shut
her
you know the damage that she can
potentially do or at least as the
uh townspeople perceive it uh has been
mitigated
but no one is entirely sure what's gonna
happen with her so they're just kind of
like
you know they're just kind of like
hanging out waiting to see what's gonna
happen and just trying not to
rile her up now so at the beginning it's
very funny because you see how very
how very like blah everybody has become
with this wit because they're just so
used to this witch because a lot most of
the people from the town
were born there um the main family that
we focus on
there's a couple other characters too
that it keeps bouncing back and forth
but the main characters that we focus on
are the grant family
who uh were not born there but they
actually transplanted
there probably like a decade or two
earlier
um you know steve the dad is a doctor
and
his wife jocelyn um had to leave her job
to come there they didn't know
obviously when they were moving to the
town that they would never be able to
leave again
so there's some resentment there they
have two teenage sons uh one of whom is
named matt who i believe is 13
and the other one tyler who i think is
or 16 or 17 years old
so a lot of the stories told from their
family and their family kind of
plays a huge part in the narrative and
they you know as i said they've
lived here for long enough uh but steve
is not
from there and so he doesn't have the
same
very very small town very kind of
insular mindset
as much as some of the other townsfolk
do that you know have been there for
generations
so the beginning of the book is actually
kind of funny because as i mentioned you
can see how very
casual everyone is about this witch it's
like basically she turns up in the house
stands in the corner and freaks everyone
out
and it's like everybody will just no
one's really allowed to touch her it's
against the law
because they don't know what's going to
rile her up and make her mad and make
her do
crazy [ __ ] like you know make the creaks
bleed or kill your animals or something
like that
if so she's standing there and it's kind
of freaky so some people just like throw
a towel over her face so she's not so
you're not like seeing her
and then she'll just kind of stand there
for several hours and then she'll like
pop up in someone else's house
or she'll just be like walking down the
street sometimes like if outsiders are
going to be in the town
you know they have the whole oh it's
like the town of catherine the witch or
whatever
but no one knows that there's an actual
witch because
they have kind of a lockdown on
information they almost have a little
bit of like a north korea like
you're not allowed to have outside cell
phones i don't think like they
give you a cell phone um that has the
app already on it
you're not really allowed to access the
internet
or the internet is very limited because
they don't want information about it
getting out
because they don't know how harmful it's
going to be the only other people that
know about the witch and know about the
curse
are this one little town that's a little
bit farther because it's just called the
point it's like a military
installation kind of thing they kind of
that's the the last resort like who you
call
like if something really like some bad
[ __ ] starts to get down
so that's kind of the situation with
this town this you know outsiders coming
to the town
uh they'll either try to hide the witch
by you know
putting a box over her or putting like a
billboard in front of where she's
decided to stand that day
or a couple times they just were like
yeah it's a woman in a costume you know
what i mean and we've had kids take
pictures with her and [ __ ] like that
uh so it's that part is almost like
comical like
like a black comedy kind of just because
uh
you know the author said in the back
that he's like well the dutch are just
very down to earth particularly like
small town dutch people and he's like
and i just
have the feeling that if a witch was
popping up in your house all the time
that's pretty much how they would react
they would just like they'll oh there
she is again and throw a towel over and
just go read the paper
so that's kind of what the beginning it
was like so like i said the beginning of
it is almost like a black comedy
and then as it goes on it starts getting
a little
weirder whereas there's kind of a group
of teenagers in town including tyler who
is um you know the
the teenage boy of the main family the
grant family
uh who a lot of the action is seen
through their eyes
they they pretty much come to the
conclusion they're like you know
they are also stuck here uh even though
they didn't have a choice about moving
here because they were little children
so they're basically well it's not fair
we can't access the internet like other
people can access it we can't um you
know they can leave the town but
you know they can't be gone for that
long uh tyler has a girlfriend who lives
in another town he can't tell her
what's going on uh in black spring and
this is really getting to him
and so a bunch of the teenagers kind of
try to get together to do some kind of
experimentation
to see if there's some way that they can
end the curse so they can all be free to
leave
because obviously as a teenager would
you don't want to be stuck in this
little bitty town for your whole entire
life and never be able to
go somewhere else or travel anywhere for
any length of time
understandably they're all upset about
it however less understandably um
one of the kids that he kind of hangs
out with the first whose name is jaden
and he's the son of uh the
butcher griselda and there's like a
whole like subplot there but you know i
don't need to go too much into that
jaden is actually kind of a psychopath
and his experimentation uh with
catherine the witch
goes a little bit too far in the sense
that he basically starts
abusing her now as i said in the law
this
is very very illegal you are really not
allowed to
touch the witch you are not allowed to
make offerings to the witch or
you're really not supposed to interact
with the witch in any way possible you
were just supposed to
not rile her up you're just supposed if
she appears in front of you you just
walk around her
you don't talk to her you don't do
anything like that
and um he basically starts provoking her
on purpose
and uh from there [ __ ] really
really really goes very very sideways in
this town
now as i said i don't really want to
ruin the end of this and if any
of anybody out there is you know speaks
dutch and has read the dutch version i'd
be very curious to know what the end of
the dutch version is
because this version is pretty horrific
all i will say is that there is some
foreshadowing
at the beginning where tyler who was i
guess is you know has a youtube channel
or whatever
and he's making some videos and he
basically
starts asking his parents or his dad in
particular because there's a whole
family dynamic thing which also plays a
lot into how it ends uh
that steve the dad uh tyler is kind of
like his favorite kid
you know what i mean um well it's not
like he doesn't love his other kid or
his wife but
you know tyler is kind of like the
golden boy and uh so that
plays a lot into what happens later on
but there's kind of a thing where tyler
is making jokes about you know who
who would you save your own kid or a
whole village in the sudan or whatever
because he was he's kind of trying to
point out
you know the hypocrisy of saying you
know yes we should save
more people like a huge village rather
than one person
but if that person is somebody that you
love obviously most people would choose
to save
the loved person rather than thousands
of strangers
so that's kind of an over like an
overarching theme of the book too
another overarching theme of the book is
how
horrible some of the people in these
small like these kind of small town
attitudes can be like
how superstition and fear of the other
always ends in tragedy uh which it does
in this book in spades um so that's kind
of the point that he's making like i
said i don't think that's too much of a
spoiler
you might be able to see where the end
is going i
sort of you know i sort of saw where it
was going but not really
it's a little bit of pet cemetery near
the end the end of it is very very
steven kangy
but but like i said you know it's it's
kind of strange because the beginning
is almost kind of like funny like almost
i don't want to say farcical
a little bit some of the characters are
a little bit
caricature-like one criticism that i saw
a lot of this didn't bother me too much
but i see where people are
coming from one criticism was that the
book was like oddly
misogynistic which
i i didn't get that too strongly but i
see what they're saying
uh there's really not a lot of female
characters in it
and the one main female character
who is one of the four kind of
viewpoints that we see throughout
is kind of a real unappealing character
she's
grotesque almost she's you know the
woman that owns the butcher shop
you know and uh it's often pointed out
like how fat and how gross she is and
how crazy she is and all this other kind
of stuff
and um it seems like the other female
characters don't really fare much better
like i said this didn't bother me that
much but i can see why it would bother
some readers also um a lot of
reviewers pointed this out as well and i
and i could cut and i
see it author real obsessed with boobs
nipples in particular
a lot of boob trauma uh in this book uh
weirdly uh it was just a very very
strange
i don't know it was very strange and and
there was one scene in particular
with the butcher lady griselda who was
essentially like sexually assaulted by
this
you know boob trauma like i said uh by
this old man like a councilman
and it really didn't i don't know why it
was in there or like why that was i
don't know it was just very strange
so so as i said if i'm i'm just very
ambivalent
i enjoyed this book i was kind of like i
couldn't really tell where it was going
so i was interested enough to keep it
going but it took me longer to read
than a book of this length would
normally take me to read
i think the problem i love the premise i
loved
the end like after everything went
batshit crazy
um i loved that like i loved all the
imagery there more boob imagery there
you'll see
but i didn't feel that much of a
connection
with any of the characters like i said a
lot of them the grant family in the
you know kind of at the center of the
story are pretty likable but they're
sort of
bland i guess um i didn't really get a
handle on them
and a lot of the other characters in the
town are kind of
caricature-like um so you couldn't
really
i don't know i just couldn't make a
connection with them or i couldn't feel
all that bad about them
uh you know if shitty things happen to
them because i wasn't really
engaged so so i think it was more
i don't know so so i think like the
character work is maybe
not as strong as it could be but
you know the imagery in this was cool
the premise is cool
i'm not sure i loved i don't know it's
this is hard because i
loved initially the idea of this
old school witch curse interacting with
modern day technology it's like we
always have to keep track of her so we
have like a witch tracking app
which is called hex which is why the
book is called that you know and
everybody like it's almost kind of like
a technological or
information lockdown to try to keep [ __ ]
about the witch from getting out to the
wider
world um a lot of people complain too
because i think that the description of
this book i think the description on the
back or the description that's on amazon
basically says well you know these
teenagers they
you know take footage of the witch and
it goes viral and you know what's gonna
happen
like when the wider world finds out
about the witch i will spoil the fact
that that does not happen
um there the teenagers do indeed uh take
a lot of footage of the witch uh and of
things happening
that of their experiments and of all the
horrible things that jayden starts doing
to the witch and abusing her
uh that is true and uh it is true that
tyler
the kind of main good teenager has sort
of a secret website
uh where he sort of writes about the
which but it's not really available to
the wider world he just kind of you know
keeps it in the town but he kind of
keeps it on the down low so he can
keep track of it and he does actually
want to
release everything to the wider world
because he makes the point
that well this is the one thing that no
one in this town has ever done
to try to lift the curse no one has
tried to
call the outside world for help everyone
has always just kind of like
gone inward and just kept everything
within this tiny little town
and that hasn't really worked out so
well the curse is still here we still
don't know
what the witch wants why she keeps
hanging around why she's popping up in
certain people's houses
you know and just we don't know you know
why she's doing it
so you know it you can't blame him for
thinking that but i am just gonna say
that there really isn't
so if you're expecting oh you know this
little town and this witch and it goes
viral and everybody finds out about it
that does not happen in the book so it's
you know it's not a terrible spoiler i'm
just saying that it kind of says that in
the description and that's
not really what happens um so it's some
of it's true but it goes into like a
completely different direction
so as i said you know i i i don't
usually
do like star ratings too much every now
and then i'll mention it
i'm going to go i don't know it's i'm
going to go three and a half on this one
like i said love the concept love
the witch turning up and i love sort of
i kind of love hate the technology and
old curse versus things like sometimes i
liked it and sometimes i was like ah
i just wish this has been all old curse
because i have a thing where i guess
because i'm an old person myself but
um where i don't love
stories that are too based in modern
technology just because i think that you
know if i read this 10 20 years from now
it would seem
really dated so i kind of like stuff
that's more
generalized or more universal or more
based in something old
to me it just seems like it dates less
so
i don't know so so it did bother me
sometimes but in general i really really
liked
the concept i really liked the concept
of the witch curse i liked the concept
of this town you know just being all
these kind of irredeemable [ __ ]
who only needed one thing to go wrong
for them all to just go
full [ __ ] 17th century stone the
witch kind of thing which like i said
that was one of the main themes of the
book that
the veneer of civilization is very very
thin and all it takes is a couple things
to go wrong
um and a couple people to get scared and
you know everything just comes crumbling
down so that's one of the things that he
was trying to say
in this which probably true as i said
you know how you feel about it there is
and you know i'll do a trigger warning
there is there's some weird ass imagery
in this
uh lots of boob trauma like lots of
cutting of nipples pinching of nipples
things like that
some cruelty to animals there is one
really weird
like animal sex scene
although it's really short it's not it
doesn't really happen it's like in
somebody's it's like a vision
i don't know this was a weird one in
case you couldn't tell
and uh the end of it kind of stephen
king he kind of gave me a little bit of
a pet cemetery vibe
i probably liked the beginning
of it like kind of the funny bits and
then
i liked the end like once everything
went you know just
[ __ ] bonkers like banana pants i i liked
that
middle a little bit
all over the place but overall a pretty
enjoyable read it's
you know it wasn't a slog or anything
like that it did take me a little bit
longer to read than usual but that
doesn't say too much about
the quality of it i was still like
pretty interested to see what would
happen even though
i didn't i you know the com the
characters weren't compelling enough to
keep me interested but the story was
because i really wanted to see how
the [ __ ] would turn out because i wasn't
really i didn't really know which
direction it was going
so anyway you know if if that sounds
interesting to you then by all means
check it out as i said it's by thomas
old hoyvelt and it's called hex
got a stephen king quote right on the
cover there just like the last one i did
i think
the true pad one as well uh but yeah so
check it out
and i'll see you on the next one bye